Three,
two,
one knee.
Yes.
Hello,
boy in.
Hi there.
Welcome.
Thank you.
Thanks for doing this.
I really appreciate it and I love what
you're doing.
I've seen your Ted Talk.
I've seen many in numerous conferences
that you've appeared at and discussions
you've given on this and for people to
jump into this right now,
what you've done is think long and hard
and devise a method to try to clean up
some of the plastic that we have
floating around in the ocean.
Famously,
the Pacific garbage patch is this
enormous patch of garbage that's between
California and Hawaii.
How did you get involved in this and
what,
what?
You're a young guy.
How old are you?
Twenty three.
Already.
Twenty three already.
You sound like,
oh my God.
How old were you when you started this?
Um,
I,
I think I started thinking about this
when I was 16 and I found that this
organization when I was 18,
that's crazy.
All you lazy fucks out there that are 16
years old that aren't doing shit with
your life.
Just think about this kid.
That's amazing.
I'm so happy.
There's people like you in the world.
No,
thank you.
Yeah.
So you started thinking about it when
you were 16 and you know,
this is something that is extremely
disturbing to anybody that's paid
attention,
especially when you see the birds that
have died with all these plastic bottle
caps inside their bodies and you know,
you see their carcasses with these
multicolored caps in them and they
thought these things were food.
It was just one of the many,
many,
many problems that occur when you have
plastic floating around and just
enormous numbers and the ocean.
Sure.
Yeah.
I mean there's really three problems
with this plastic.
First of all,
obviously the ecosystem damage.
I think they're right about 800 species
that actually could go extinct because
of this plastic pollution.
And then there's the economic threat in
terms of damage to fisheries,
damage to tourism and things like that.
I think it's around $13 billion dollars
a year according to the UN.
And then thirdly,
there's the health impact or the
potential health impact because these
tiny plastic pieces,
they actually ended up in the fish we
eat,
uh,
that take chemicals with it.
And uh,
yeah,
that ends up on our dinner plate as
well.
So what was it that prompted you to
dedicate,
essentially dedicate your young life to
this?
Sure.
Yeah.
So I've always been very passionate
about technology and just building
things.
I think sort of having an idea in your
mind and then seeing that become reality
and be able to touch it and things like
that.
I think,
uh,
there's literally no better feeling in
the world than that.
So I've been building my own thing since
it was two years old I think for
starting with things like tree houses
and zip lines,
but then going into sort of computers
and explosives and rockets and things
like that,
which was a lot of fun,
but it wasn't very useful I would say.
Um,
so it's kind of looking for something,
sort of a,
something that real to,
to work on a real problem.
And that's what I then came across when
I was 16 years old,
it was scuba diving in Greece and I came
across more plastic bags of fish and I
wondered why can we just clean this up?
And uh,
that question sort of kept circling
around in my head and um,
yeah,
I sort of thought about how could we do
this.
The ocean is pretty big and then
eventually came up with there's a dod to
use these natural ocean currents,
uh,
to let us collect the plastic.
And so how do you have many different
prototypes?
Did you started with and you eventually
wound up with what you have now and have
you started implementing them yet?
Oh yeah.
I mean,
so the,
the concept that was presented back in
2012 with my first tedx stoke and if you
compare that to where we are right now,
it's sort of day and night of a
difference.
So,
um,
yeah,
through testing and through all these
prototypings um,
yeah,
obviously there has been a lot of
development there,
but the key idea has stayed the same.
That instead of going after the plastic
with boats and nets,
which will take roundabout 79,000
years to clean up just as great pacific
garbage patch.
Instead of doing that,
we let the plastic come to us.
So we use a,
basically in network,
a fleet of very long floating barriers
which are oriented in a u shape and they
float around and they kind of act like a
massive pacman.
So,
um,
yeah,
like a,
like a funnel brings the plastic towards
it,
the network ocean currents push it
against,
it,
moves towards the center,
becomes very concentrated and wanted to
concentrated well then it's easy to get
it out and ship it to land for
recycling.
It has this started yet,
um,
so with the past,
so we were founded four years ago in
that time on one side we did the
reconnaissance,
so we mapped the patch with 30 boats and
an airplane at the same time to really
understand how much is out there,
which turns out to be one point 8
trillion pieces floating in this great
Pacific garbage patch.
Uh,
and on the other hand,
we've done all the testing.
So we've done hundreds of scale model
tests,
we've done prototypes back in Europe on
the Nazi and actually right now we're,
we're manufacturing the first real
cleanup system which is scheduled to be
launched from San Francisco to the Great
Pacific garbage patch around two or
three months time.
So has anything been used,
like is there a proof of concept of have
you done like,
real large scale testing where you've
shown that you can actually do this?
Well,
I mean we've done a lot of subsystem
testing,
so the,
the prototypes in the North Sea for
example,
where there were these 12 meters
sections and we managed though to keep
that in one piece.
So,
um,
but then also the plastic capturing that
worked very well in the lab.
Um,
but yeah,
the,
the real,
the real proof of course has to come
from this one real system in the great
pacific garbage patch collecting
plastic.
And that's what we really hope to
achieve this year.
So this is the one,
right?
The Great Pacific
garbage patch is the largest.
Yes,
because cal between California and
Hawaii.
Hawaiian.
Yeah.
So the five areas in the world where our
plastic concentrates a,
this is by far the largest one,
therefore others,
uh,
but they are,
they combined Lee a contain less plastic
than this one in the,
in the nurses.
Do we know what it is?
Probably because of Asia.
So Asia has,
uh,
has quite a big problem in terms of that
they,
they use a lot of plastic but they don't
have a good infrastructure.
So by far the largest source of plastic
flowing into the ocean is also this,
uh,
there's one continent and what's being
released,
they're naturally by because of the
currents ends up in the North Pacific.
It's such a strange problem because it
wasn't something that was discussed in
the eighties and the nineties.
It was nothing.
And then all of the sudden,
somewhere in the year 2000,
I remember hearing about the massive
amount of plastic we have in the ocean
and it just,
it just made sense.
I was like,
oh,
well of course,
of course it's going to wind up there.
But the sheer size of it is staggering.
Yeah.
And I think that to me the worrying
thing is that it's a persistent problem.
So with many other kinds of pollution,
so when you sort of turn off the tap,
it's will be sold by itself.
Think about,
for example,
the,
the ozone hole with the cfcs,
uh,
but with this,
like if you turn off the tap,
the problem is still there and in 100
years it will still be there.
So I think to really solve it,
you need to do two things.
One site,
we have to close the tap.
On the other hand,
we also need to clean it up.
Jamie just pulled up a size comparison
where it shows one point 6 million
square kilometers of area twice the size
of Texas or three times the size of
France.
Yeah.
So this is a study we published a few a
few weeks ago.
So this was the result of the
recognizance effort.
Um,
and it's kind of funny,
like every other news outlet used at
different size comparison.
So I think it was CNN that says,
what's the size of Mongolia?
Um,
we always use Texas.
Yeah,
Texas is America.
We use Texas for everything four times
of California as well.
So yeah,
it's pretty,
pretty big area.
It's insane.
And it's getting bigger,
I'm sure.
Uh,
yeah.
So the,
the,
the area doesn't really change.
It's more of the,
the concentration concentration of it.
When did we realize that this was an
issue like collectively scientists,
geologists,
so there hasn't been that have been sort
of small sampling efforts since the
seventies.
So back then it was the first time
plastic was described as being something
that floats in the ocean,
but it really only entered the public
consciousness,
I think in the late nineties there was
this,
uh,
this captain Charles Moore who,
um,
were sort of sailing through it and he
saw this plastic and he was like,
we need to describe this.
And then he did a,
a scientific paper on it and yeah.
And actually I think he was the one that
turned the term great pacific garbage
patch.
He was riding his boat through it for a
long period of time,
I guess.
Yeah,
I think it was,
um,
it was participating in some sailing
race and he went through it and then,
yeah,
he just saw that.
So he was the sort of the canary in the
coal mine,
I guess.
Yeah.
What is it,
one of those things where it's hard to
get different governments to act on this
because you know,
like who's responsible for it?
The ocean.
Yeah,
I think it's a sort of tragic tragedy of
the Commons,
right?
Where it's international waters,
sort of everyone's problem,
but at the same time legally it's no
problem.
So,
um,
yeah,
and besides that,
what I really felt when I started the
ocean cleanup was that I think everyone
wanted this problem to be solved,
but at the same time we didn't really
have a way to do it.
There was somebody wasn't any technology
to do that and that's why I thought,
well perhaps this is an opportunity to
combine my interests,
have a,
solving this problem,
but b,
also developing technology,
which is what we did.
Is there anyone else doing this?
So there are many organizations working
on the,
on the prevention insight,
right?
So educating people,
thinking about policies,
those kinds of things,
which is very important I think.
Uh,
but uh,
yeah,
unfortunately we're the only ones that
sort of do the technology side of it and
yeah,
I wish more people would do it.
If somebody else would clean the ocean,
that'd be fine with us as well.
Uh,
but until somebody else does it,
yeah,
we were kind of the ones that have to
do.
That's so fascinating to me that other 7
billion people on the planet sometimes
it really does just take one person to,
to act one person,
do something about something that,
I mean I'm aware of many people aware of
many people listening have heard about
this and that and it's sort of one of
those things that's in the back of your
mind that doesn't affect you on a daily
basis.
So you say,
well that's a tragedy.
That's a terrible thing,
but it's not my problem.
I have my own problems.
But you was one person decided to do
something about it.
And the fact that you did when you were
16 is so fascinating to me and someone
has to do it right,
but isn't that weird?
Someone has to,
but nobody was doing shit until you came
along.
That's very interesting.
Yeah.
I sometimes wonder sometimes people ask
me like why,
why do you do it?
And like the as my answer would be like
why not?
Why isn't everyone doing it?
My one thing that I was thinking was,
and this isn't my same feeling about
pollution,
air pollution,
is that once they figured out a way to
use whatever's in the particular,
it's an air pollution as a resource.
Sure.
And make it valuable.
Then people are going to be running to
extract it out of the skies.
And I felt the same way about the
Pacific garbage patch and all the other
ocean currents where they have this
issue.
So what is it?
The currents bring everything together
collectively into one area just because
of the way the ocean moves.
Exactly.
So you have these sort of the,
the current at the equator and then you
have these boundary currents and it sort
of acts like the,
um,
like the sinking your best up.
Right?
So it's sort of where all the plastic
wants to go.
Now.
Is it possible to take that stuff,
all of that Pacif,
all those disgusting particles and use
it for something?
Yeah,
I mean,
sure.
I'm actually a few examples with me.
I'm in a bank but not here right now.
Grab it.
Do you want to go grab it?
No,
I'll do it a bit.
I can describe it.
Okay.
It's podcasts anyways.
So,
um,
so what we do is we take the plastic out
and we um,
we recycled that,
we've developed a process for this and
we can turn it into new products,
actually the pair of sunglasses that are
finally being able to wear after a
dreaded northern European winter.
They were already made that out of
plastic that we took out of the Great
Pacific garbage patch.
And you're wearing sunglasses that are
recycled from the ocean.
Exactly.
And the idea is that we can do anything
with this,
right,
so you can imagine sort of the part of
your next car or your chair or whatever,
you can make that out of ocean plastic
and what we think is that the material
itself isn't valuable enough,
but it's really the story behind it.
So the fact that you can say,
well it's made out of the Great Pacific
garbage patch which we think will add
value.
So it's like the difference between a
normal pebble and the piece of the
Berlin Wall,
it's one is worth shit and the other is
worth something.
So that's what we kind of want to use as
a way to,
to then be able to fund the operations
of the clinic.
I think that's a fantastic idea and I
think that'll be a huge value for
people.
I mean,
I think people really want to buy
something that they know is recycled out
of something that was choking fish and
birds to death.
Yeah.
And not only that,
but he does his turning plastic from the
ocean into $200 shoes.
Sports sportswear maker is teaming up
with something to sell three new shoes
made with plastic pulled from the ocean.
It's like,
wow,
that's awesome for the kind of stuff you
can do.
So in this example,
so I did,
I,
she didn't use a plastic from the ocean.
They,
I think they just said that for
marketing reasons,
they make that from plastic that sort
of,
they call it ocean bound.
So.
Oh,
those lie motherfuckers.
God dammit.
They got them.
Yeah.
That's bullshit.
So it's on the way to the ocean.
Yeah.
Which I guess is any,
could be anything.
It was like we were going to throw it
up,
make sneakers.
Right.
Oh,
that's horrible.
it's still catching venture.
Perhaps some of those.
Do you have some of those that.
They're very cool.
I liked,
I liked them and I liked the people that
work on it and everything,
but that's a lie.
Yeah.
Well yeah,
a white light a little bit.
Yeah.
Um,
but uh,
yeah,
so I mean the composition of the plastic
that we'll be pulling out of the ocean
is pretty unique.
It's a,
it's quite degraded because of the
decades of UV light heading it,
so,
so we really had to develop a new
process to do this,
so probably maybe a year so it will be
actually be able to launch the first
line of products made out of sort of
real the real deal.
The plastic actually coming out of the
ocean.
That's excellent.
So you're going to sell like raw plastic
and is there an issue of who owns the
plastic?
I mean even [inaudible] is in the
Commons of the ocean in international
waters.
I think it'd be hilarious if somebody
would sort of raise their hand and say,
oh,
that's my plastic.
I put it in there,
then we have another kind of legal
issue.
But if it becomes a resource like oil.
Yeah.
I think there's some,
the salvage laws that say if a few sort
of salvage something into the shoe
oceans,
you can actually keep it.
So that doesn't appear to be a,
an issue.
Uh,
but yeah,
definitely it will be a sort of closing
the circle and will be a fun project
too.
Yeah,
I mean it sounds,
it sounds like an amazing thing and I
guarantee people would be very,
very interested to buy things that they
know we're made out of something that
was really a horrible
side effect of civilization.
Yeah.
I think if you have the choice between a
normal.
Let's use this sunglass example.
Yeah,
a normal pair or a pair of coming out of
the ocean.
I think nine out of 10 people would
choose the latter.
Oh,
for sure.
I mean I think it would be giant for
companies to,
to advertise that we only use 100
percent recycled from the ocean plastic
and when exactly that would be gigantic.
Now how long do you think it would be
before this could be a reality?
Um,
so the first system it's currently being
assembled,
so we are renting a former naval base
in,
at the San Francisco Bay where it's
currently being put together.
It's still relatively small system.
It's 2000 feet in length.
So eventually there'll be almost a
double the size,
but this is,
this one will be launched in pretty late
June,
early July.
Uh,
then we'll take it out the first,
the first deployment will not yet be
directly in the patch,
so we're just deploying it ran 300 miles
of the coast just to make sure that it
works well.
Sort of a final rehearsal if that goes
well then by probably around August we
should be ready to take it all the way
to the patch and hopefully soon after
that,
collect the first plastic and then we
hope to have the first shipment of first
plastic back back in port before the end
of the year.
And we think that will be such a
symbolic moment for,
for 60 years,
man has been putting plastic into the
ocean and from that moment onwards we're
also taking it back out again.
That's amazing.
And you feel like you can get 40 percent
of the garbage patch in 10 years.
It's actually.
So with a fleet of 60 of these cleanup
systems,
we should be able to clean up half this
great pacific garbage patch every five
years,
which of course the more honorable um,
yeah,
I mean,
and you could get faster if you want
more,
if you put in more systems.
Of course.
Where are you guys getting funding from?
Um,
so so far we've been very generously
supported by but mostly individuals
actually.
So uh,
ranging from people that just donate 50
bucks to two people like Marc Benioff,
the founder of salesforce and couple of
other very high net worth individuals.
If someone wanted to donate,
how would they do?
So
yeah,
just go to the website,
the ocean cleanup.com
and feel free to get in touch with us.
So mostly individuals,
mostly wealthy philanthropists.
Yeah.
So that has gotten us to around 35 to
$40,000,000
right now,
which has been enough to fund all these
years of research and development,
the whole mapping of the patch as well
as the construction of this first system
right now.
So,
uh,
so that should get us to the point where
we're sort of proven technology.
And then for the scaleup,
the idea is that basically any company
can,
can go and fund their own system.
We estimate the cost of every system to
be around 5 million.
Um,
basically you,
um,
you know,
the system will be around a kilometer,
that's plenty of space for logos.
The world is watching.
So it's like this massive billboard
floating out there.
So,
uh,
so the idea is that any company can sort
of fund or are individual,
even
some of the racist Nike can be like,
fuck you,
Adidas were actually doing this for
real.
Just kidding.
Adidas,
that will be Hillary.
It would be hilarious.
So what is the process in taking the
plastic from the ocean and converting
into usable plastic like that you would
use in sunglasses?
Um,
so,
uh,
the first thing you'd do is you can have
your washer do sorted,
you scrub it to,
to get you so disease,
very clean,
sort of a fragments of plastic.
Uh,
then we,
uh,
we do.
There's a process called compounding
where you sort of remelted and add some,
some additives and make it into what you
call pellets.
So these are sort of these,
uh,
beat sized particles which can be fed
into any machine in the world.
So say an Ikea machine for furniture or
tesla machine for,
for cars.
Um,
and um,
yeah,
so that process we can add to custom
develops tailor made for,
for our feedstock because it's such a
unique composition.
That's amazing.
It's really fascinating because I think
that that will be a hugely desirable
form of construction.
Like if you can prove that the plastic
that you use was made and is actually,
it's a benefit to,
to get that plastic and make things out
of it.
Yeah,
I mean the,
it's still more expensive obviously than
just normal plastic because we have to
collect it from 1200 miles off shore,
but on the other hand,
so just by selling it as plastic,
I don't think that will be a good
business,
but making it into sort of going further
into value chain up to the consumer.
I think that can make sense because
again,
to use the sunglass example,
it's probably around a 100 grams of
material,
uh,
so that would take about a maybe a
dollar to collect and you know,
what's a dollar on the hundred and $20
pair of sunglasses.
Right.
So,
um,
so I think that really going at all the
way up to,
in the value chain,
that's where you can really add the
value.
Well,
you know,
one of the things that was shocking to
me when I was investigating plastic is
that I didn't know that plastic you can
make plastic out of hemp.
The hemp plastic is actually
biodegradable.
Yeah.
And sugar cane.
And there's many sort of bio based types
of plastic that the thing is though,
that there's,
this is very,
very sort of complicated and
controversial world of sort sorted the
bioplastics,
uh,
because you have something called
biobased and biodegradable,
so you can make plastic out of say
sugarcane,
uh,
which is chemically exactly the same as
plastic that it was made from crude oil
and it would take the same amount of
time for a two degree.
So a base doesn't necessarily mean that
it's biodegradable and vice versa,
so,
so it's um,
it's a very complicated world that even
sometimes her experts on this on plastic
pollution being confused about it.
So let alone sort of the general
population.
So uh,
and in,
in short,
there isn't yet sort of the holy grill
of this type of plastic that on one hand
is very good in terms of performance in
a usable life.
And then when it,
for example,
enter the ocean just degrades in,
in a matter of days or months.
So,
uh,
but I think that would be,
you know,
there will be a great innovation.
Is the quality of biodegradable plastic
inferior to bio based but non
biodegradable.
Yeah.
Or it's.
And it's mostly limited in terms of
applications so you can really get
everything
like the actual physical plastic.
Does it feel different to the touch
it's.
Have you?
Yeah.
So it's,
it usually makes more noise.
It's more sort of crumbly,
so it's brittle or something.
Right.
Interesting.
Well that makes sense.
Right?
Obviously it's going to.
So if you're going to make water bottles
out of biodegradable plastic,
they're probably going to leak.
Yeah,
yeah.
That's yeah,
that.
That's not possible yet.
So they're compostable.
That's another thing.
You have compostable plastic,
which,
which you can use for water bottles,
but then the only way for it to degrade
who'd be to be in sort of this
industrial composter,
we have a temperature of 100 degrees and
pressure and things like that and it
would integrate in the ocean.
So it's a.
it's a very complicated area.
Third had Paul stamets on who's in my
colleges and he was talking about all
the different fungus that could be
potentially engineered to eat plastic.
This is another thing that they're
working on.
Yeah.
So that,
that
of course it would be great to have on
landfills and things like sheets.
It's a.
it's a process that we're also
investigating for our recycling because
one thing you could do is you could take
that plastic and then using either
enzymes or indeed fung,
fung guy and things like that.
You could turn it back into biomass.
So from that biomass you could make
anything else against it.
You could make a bio based plastic,
for example.
So does this change your relationship
with plastic?
I mean,
when you sit there and you're drinking
out of this plastic bottle,
do you think I'm going to have to clean
this fucking thing up someday?
Yeah,
I,
yeah,
but on the Ariana and also not against
plastic because I realized that without
plastic,
say modern medicine will be very
difficult.
That plastic lot more food waste would
be produced and without plastic we
wouldn't be able to clean the ocean.
Big Ocean actually a lot of the
components of our cleanup system
actually.
Maybe we can pull up an image of the
thing being built right now.
Um,
so that's actually a lot of the parts of
that are made out of plastic.
So,
um,
so,
so it's kind of ironic.
It's poetic embolism.
Yeah.
Here it is very far.
Solving fire with fire.
So yes,
I don't think we can live without
plastic and I don't think we should want
to.
I think it's really just about managing
the material in a way that it doesn't
end up in the ocean,
which means that it ed comes back to the
material being valuable enough at the
end of life because if,
if it's cheaper to recycle than to not
recycle will,
then obviously it would happen and there
needs to be good infrastructure for
that.
And then I think as a final,
sort of a final safety net,
we need technologies like this to sort
of intercepted in river mouths as well
as sort of clean up the legacy of the 60
years that we're having in the middle of
the ocean.
But I don't think we can live with that
place.
No,
I don't think so.
Either.
Not yet.
And are when you're looking at the water
and you see the plastic that is in this
Pacific garbage patch on the other,
the other four patches,
how deep does that plastic go from the
surface?
Um,
so for most of the plastic really stays
on our near the surface.
So we've,
we've done expedition student for that
too to measure it.
And that's actually why our system only
goes three meters deep because that's so
below that,
there's virtually no plastic anymore.
Interesting.
So it was only about nine feet.
So when your,
when your trunk,
when you see the little tiny itty bitty
pieces,
it seems like as the plastic breaks down
over decades,
it becomes like almost like a gelatinous
sort of chunky thing.
It's called microplastics are.
You've sort of these particles that look
a bit almost like grains of sand,
right?
Uh,
which are sort of really small.
Even those we measured our primarily in
those top three meters or nine feet in.
Um,
so,
and,
and another surprising finding,
I think from,
from those explanations,
was that still more than 99 percent of
the plastic is larger than a millimeter.
So larger than those,
those very tiny pieces,
which means that on one hand,
I think that's good news because that
means it's not too late because
obviously the smaller to get the more
harmful they get a,
they end up in the food chain,
but they also are harder to clean up.
Right?
So,
uh,
so it's 100,
it's not too late.
So it's the good,
the good news I think,
but on the other hand,
it also means that there's still 99
percent of a plastic out there that,
uh,
over the next few decades will become
microplastics as well if we don't clean
it up.
So there's sort of this ticking time
bomb out there that um,
you know,
if we just leave it there,
the amount of microplastics could
increase over a hundred fold over the
next few decades and then we will be in
a,
in a,
in March,
worse situation than we are today.
So have marine biologists done studies
on the impact in that particular area in
terms of populations of fish and marine
life?
Uh,
yeah.
So,
so there's many species that are being
affected on one side due to ingestion on
the,
on the other side through entanglement.
So actually another finding of our study
was that almost half of the plastic by
mass is things like ropes and fishing
nets,
which of course disastrous.
Well first of all,
four propellers for,
for boats that go out.
Oh,
photo indeed.
So arena,
terrible photo of a,
a turtle that,
I mean it looks like it's caught in a
bush,
it's just this massive net that this
thing is swimming around with this thing
attached to his body.
That's one of the things that I was
going to ask you about is cleaning up
the nets because uh,
we had talked to someone who was
explaining that every time they fish,
a lot of times they'll cut the nets
lose.
Yeah.
So it's probably a combination of
accidental loss and intentional lots.
But yeah,
I mean this amount of net really was
quite,
quite staggering.
And did you,
do you remember who was bringing that
up,
Jamie?
Somebody.
Somebody brought that up that they just
released the nets and that it's
commonplace and it was stunning because
we were like,
what?
Every time they do that,
yeah,
the netscape cut in,
they get damaged so they just cut the
nets loose and the nets are plastic too.
So.
But that's insane that that's legal,
that they do that,
that they don't have.
Yeah.
It's not Lego,
but it's not really legal.
No.
But they're lost for this.
But obviously,
how do you know that people do that?
It's very hard to,
to monitor the middle of the ocean.
Yeah,
I mean I guess you should probably have
some sort of a gps tracking on your net.
Yeah,
I mean that could be one thing.
Or You could think about a need market
based solutions where there will be a
financial incentive if they bring their
nets.
Sure.
Yeah.
In some sort of a penalization if they
don't.
What is this Jamie?
The impact and abandoned ocean fishing
nets on marine life.
Chris Ryan or Duncan.
Oh,
okay.
That makes sense.
Google says,
Oh man,
that is just so.
It's so sad that it's such a wasteful,
dismissive sort of thing to do.
Just cut it loose and it's gone.
It's in the ocean.
No worries.
Sure.
So that's,
I mean that's a very obvious kind of
impact.
And then another thing that was also a
study done recently,
so we looked at the,
the concentrations of plastic versus
naturally occurring the marine life in
this garbage patch.
And then what we saw was that there is
180 times more plastic at the surface.
Then sort of natural food for birds and
turtles and things like that.
So you can imagine if you are a turtle
at the surface of this garbage patch and
you sort of take a bite to eat,
there's 180 times larger chance that you
eat plastic rather than a piece of
plankton.
Right?
Um,
and what we found was that this
concentration is so high that it
connection.
You have this chemical impact,
uh,
where um,
yeah,
where these chemicals have a potential
health impact on these organisms as well
as um,
a species further up the food food web,
including US humans.
So have we noticed that?
Have people been tested and shown to
have ingested plastic that they've
gotten through eating tuna or something
like that.
So the plastic itself isn't the thing
that chemicals,
chemicals that are attached to the
plastic.
And for example you see is that,
for example,
in Greenland,
like the native communities that really
rely on fish,
they have much higher cancer rates.
They have a much higher concentrations
of mercury,
other heavy metals as well as these
persistent organic pollutants.
He thinks that attached to the press,
to the plastic in Greenland.
Yeah,
like the,
like these sort of these native
communities that rely on fish and other
sea life
there to eat.
This is a recent trend that they have
higher rates of cancer.
Um,
yeah.
I don't know how recent it is,
but the past few decades I can imagine.
But yeah,
that's really linked to their,
their marine,
uh,
the consumption of marine sources.
But um,
you know,
obviously it's hard to say well how many
percent of that is just heavy metals.
Yeah.
For as far as what's coming by plastic.
But sure,
if you,
um,
if you look at the kind of chemicals and
you look at the lab tests that they've
done with that,
those chemicals.
Yeah.
They are not very good for you.
No,
I've heard that if you leave a water
bottle like this in your car and it gets
hot out,
that the water will,
a plastic will leach into the water.
So.
Correct.
Yeah.
So I think it depends on the kind of
plastic,
but you have,
I think with this prayer,
the liner would contain salads and
things like that.
So,
um,
yeah,
I wouldn't do that.
Um,
so there's,
you know,
when you look at this chemicals you
have,
you have two kinds of things you should
I think worry about.
One is the chemicals that are actually
in the plastic and secondly there's
these chemicals that just float around
in the ocean and then can attach to the
plastic,
uh,
when they,
um,
because they sort of act like this
chemical sponge,
the plastic wants to repel water and
those chemicals too.
So they kind of act like a magnet
towards each other.
Um,
and especially the latter one is well
studied and we see that a lot on the,
on the,
on,
on the plastic.
Uh,
but the,
the former one,
yeah,
it's even an issue here.
If in your car,
for example,
it's an issue in your car,
like also.
Yeah.
Well if you leave it like in a hot car
and.
Right,
right.
Right.
Now the question was,
is even if you're scooping out all that
plastic out of the ocean,
is it still leaving chemicals that will,
will never be able to get up?
Um,
so I think the chemicals mostly actually
it,
it collects more chemicals than it sort
of leaches out.
So,
uh,
because of those,
those sort of legacy chemicals like the,
the pcbs and ddt sort of things that we
use for a insulators.
And I'm a pesticide spec in the maybe
the forties to sixties.
So these,
um,
these actually,
uh,
the,
the plastic attracts those chemicals.
So,
uh,
in a way you kind of also remove a bit
of those chemicals and we actually have
to wash them out before we do the
recycling because you don't want those
in your,
your products.
So there's actually some sort of a
benefit to having those plastics in the
water.
I mean,
not that you would encourage people to
put in the water,
but there is some,
some natural benefit.
Um,
yeah,
I mean it's sort of.
Yeah,
I mean I,
I cannot really say how many percent of
those legacy chemicals we would be
pulling out with the plastic,
but yeah,
I mean you could say,
you could argue it's sort of an added
benefit to removing it.
Not sure having plastic in here
now have you extended this line of
thinking to some of the other problems
in the ocean,
like these heavy metals?
Um,
well,
so I really hope is that the cleanup can
sort of become a symbol of how we should
use or how we should use technology to
solve problems of our time.
So when you,
um,
and I think a lot of it comes down to
that we shouldn't sort of protest what
we shouldn't agree with it,
but we should build the things we should
build a future that we do agree with.
Um,
so when you look at the past few hundred
years of modernity in our civilization,
what we see is dramatic positive trends
in terms of health,
wealth,
education,
violence,
and we had steven pinker on your show,
right?
Um,
so I think that's really,
really positive trends.
We've done a good job in that.
And that all comes down to our ability
to sort of imagine things that don't
exist yet.
So it was sort of technology and
innovation and being able to work,
uh,
work together in an effective way,
which is think about the corporation.
Um,
so,
so I think those have been,
um,
sort of very good trends and I think
what we should do is we should also
think about how to apply those to the
area outside of our own species and to
the rest of the environment because when
you look at all those positive trends
over the past few hundred years,
um,
and then yeah,
that's all good.
But there's one very big exception which
is the impact to the environment.
It's almost like we've had all the
success at the cost of the environment
and,
but I think that instead of there's some
people that have sort of a more
reactionary field to this and they say,
well,
look at all these problems.
It was created by businesses and by
technology.
So we should stay as far away from those
things as possible.
And I think that's sort of,
um,
you know,
that's sort of stupid.
I think that it really just shows that
these are very powerful ways of getting
things done and I think a much more
effective way was to sort of apply that
what has worked in other areas and then
also apply that to the area of the
environment.
So,
so I don't think,
you know,
I,
for example,
think that the,
the car problem is not going to be
solved by bending cars I think is going
to be sold,
but electric cars and I don't think the,
the,
the pollution problem is going to be
solved by everyone becoming Vegan.
I think it's going to be solved by
things like lab grown meat and other
kinds of alternatives.
Um,
so,
and that's why I also think that,
um,
yeah,
the ocean cleanup or the plastic
pollution problem is not going to be
solved by sort of people trying to do
their own little bits.
And I'm trying to live without plastic
or things like that I think is going to
be solved by,
um,
you know,
things like plastics that do not harm to
the environment as well as technologies
like the ocean cleanup to sort of clean
up after itself.
So,
um,
yeah,
and I hope that there can be a sort of a
symbol of that approach.
I like what you just said there because
I,
I've always thought that technology will
most likely sort out most of these
issues if we apply enough attention to
it and that one of the real issues is
when someone creates some sort of a new
technology,
they really don't have the ability to
see 50 years down the line what's going
to happen with the side effects,
the residual effects.
And I think that's a big part of what
happened with plastic.
And I don't think the solution is,
you know,
making an accent of a piece of rock and
living in the woods.
I think that the solution is trying to
have a long term comprehensive approach
to how we use various technologies and
also various resources so that we don't
have another pacific garbage patch and
some new technology 5,100,
200 years from now.
I mean if you went to the ocean 200
years ago,
you'd see none of this.
So this is a very,
very,
very recent issue that's compounding at
a staggering rate.
Sure.
Yeah.
I agree with what you say there and
it's.
Yeah,
it's,
it's really just about,
uh,
so I don't think.
I think there's other people that think
that technology is inherently neutral.
It's not good or bad,
but I think that's not true.
If you compare,
I know some bio terrorist weapon which
you could event or you could invent a
machine to clean the ocean,
I would say I would argue those are not
equally a good things to,
to develop.
So when technology isn't a inheriting
neutral means it's sort of
deterministic.
So the inventor kind of puts a certain
direction in the product already and I
think that can be used in our advantage
or to phrase it differently.
I think there is a responsibility at
with inventors and entrepreneurs to
build things that are more good than bad
and actually plastic.
I would still argue that plastic is a
net positive technology and it was
invented as a solution.
Uh,
it saves a lot of weights,
a lot of people got hurt when,
when people use glass bottles and things
like that.
So back in the day this was invented as
a,
as a solution,
but it has this negative side effects.
And then I think we should now think
about,
well,
what technologies can we develop to
manage that negative side effect?
And probably those have again,
a small negative side effect,
but you can think about it like a
compounding sort of staircase of,
um,
of net positive technologies.
I think eventually that's how we can
actually solve this problem.
So in this country there's a tremendous
amount of recycling,
but how effective is that recycling?
Yeah.
I think the amount of recycling is
actually pretty low in the,
in the US compared to other countries
that can do everything better over here.
Yeah.
I've noticed that.
What countries the best at it,
I think like Germany or Switzerland,
that this kind of country that really
are.
And what do they do differently?
Um,
they just think they just put more money
in it and I think most of the waste and
the US is actually being landfilled.
So,
and what's used to be recycled actually
was sent to China.
But now like I think this year or last
year,
China said,
well,
no,
we don't want your waste anymore.
So,
uh,
so now I think there will be a lot of
investments in new recycling facilities
in the US.
Now how does that get recycled save?
You use this water bottle and you empty
and then you throw it into the recycle
container.
What happens?
Um,
so yeah,
I mean very much depends on the
location,
but I'm to just use an example,
um,
of where I live in,
back in Holland.
Uh,
so they,
um,
they,
you actually,
they collect the plastic separately.
Then it goes to a facility where they
sort the different kinds of plastic,
they get out all the contaminants and
uh,
make that into two new pellets.
And the problem there is really the,
um,
the lack of demand for recycled plastic
because I think a lot of companies that,
yeah,
that build products because basically
virgin,
so new plastic is so cheap,
they'd rather just do what they're used
to and I'm not,
they don't want to see any risks with
their materials.
So they just choose for the safe option,
the,
the new kinds of plastics.
So I think if you want to do,
if you want to promote recycling,
uh,
I would actually say well promotes the
use of recycled material because as long
as there's a demand then the price will
go up and then automatically more
recycling what would happen.
Yeah.
There's very little demand for recycled
plastic.
Look,
it's not something that you hear about
on a regular basis.
Like people that are clamoring to get
only recycled plastic.
Yeah.
And I think that,
I think maybe that's,
um,
that could be another nice side effect
of what we do because we can kind of
make this sort of recycled plastic a bit
more sexy.
Perfect word.
Yeah.
I think that's exactly what it is.
Have you extended this line of thinking
to other environmental concerns like
pollution in terms of chemical spills
and pollution in the air and things
along those lines?
Yeah.
I have quite a few more ideas I would
say,
but yeah,
I would really,
really wouldn't be good for the ocean
cleanup if I would get distracted.
Well,
I want you to farm those ideas to other
people because I think guys like you are
insanely valuable.
Like that one person really did sort of
germinate the seed and get this project
moving.
It's very unusual.
Outliers like yourself,
very humble guy.
I'm sure you don't think of yourself in
an outlier,
but you most certainly are.
It's one of the most valuable things
about civilizations,
the occasional person who steps out
amongst the masses and does something
pretty radical that almost everybody
around them was aware it was an issue.
And that's what you're doing.
Yeah.
I think there could be much more people
that do things like that.
Yeah,
I think I would think so.
But I don't see it.
That's what it's so fascinating about
guys,
Iq is that this is not a very common
thing to do,
but it's a very common problem.
Yeah.
Well maybe that's because when you hear
about people doing cool,
cool shit,
it's usually when they're already sort
of doing those things and it's not.
When they kind of started thinking about
this,
so then I guess people can be
intimidated.
Like how.
I don't know how to run a company of 100
people.
I didn't know how to uh,
how to get these things done.
But when I looked back at myself four or
five years ago,
I really didn't have a bloody clue what
I was doing.
What you were a baby.
Yeah,
exactly.
Five years ago or 18.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah.
That's a baby I wasn't even born yet.
No.
So,
so,
but that really doesn't matter.
I mean it sits about just getting
started.
Sure.
And being willing to learn and just
being open to feedback and just trying
many different things and seeing what
works and what doesn't work,
especially at the beginning of done
hundreds of things that didn't work the
first time I tried a fundraising.
I send a cold email to 300 companies and
ask to ask for sponsorship.
And I think one replied and said,
this is a horrible idea.
You should go back to school.
Um,
so that wasn't heard.
That one.
Yeah.
Put that one on your wall.
I will do that.
It's a good idea.
Um,
so.
So that was very successful.
And then I tried crowdfunding and raise
a few million bucks and allowed us to
get started.
So isn't that amazing?
Yeah.
So it's just about sort of doing this
trial and error.
So just like we developed a technology
in a very iterative fashion.
It's also about developing yourself,
I think in a,
in an iterative fashion and sort of just
just get started.
Well,
what my point being is that when someone
like you does make something happen and
once you get the ball rolling,
you can be a catalyst for so many other
projects getting launched because it's
attached to you like you're a person,
like you've got the fire,
okay,
you've got the fire,
so you put the fire over here.
Now this fire will start here.
Let me bring an end to this,
this project,
this can start and it seems to me that
getting that fire,
getting that initial ember is one of the
most difficult aspects and creating any
sort of technology in terms,
especially in terms of something so
complex where you're extracting things
that are potentially dangerous from the
environment and creating a net positive
effect and then using that plastic to
recycle.
There's so much good Karma,
for lack of a better word,
attached to something like that.
And,
and for a person like me,
when I hear that your sunglasses are
made from the Pacific garbage patch,
I get excited.
I'm like,
Oh,
where can I buy these fucking sunglasses
next year?
Yeah,
well I'll buy him that,
but that,
that does get exciting to be bold.
So it seems to me that this excitement
that you're bringing is contagious and
you could potentially use it to spread
other ideas that could also be
environmentally positive.
Yeah.
Well I certainly hope that our people
will think about sort of what kind of
the ocean cleanup can I built,
which isn't cleaning plastic from the
ocean.
So I hope people sort of already do
that.
Um,
but yeah,
I mean it's a good,
good point.
I should sort of think about sort of
what to do with these other ideas.
Like yeah,
a few of them are sort of thought about
that I kind of want to do myself
eventually,
uh,
which would not be in the next few
years,
but burning.
Yeah.
Do you have like a long
term plan for other stuff?
What are you going to do if you,
the oceans are all beautiful and blue,
you're like,
shit,
I mean what do I do?
And the goal is really to help ourselves
out of business.
Right?
So one day we hope we're done.
I don't want to be the garbage man of
the ocean forever,
sort of not the best title anyway.
Um,
so,
so the,
I think we did target that we set for
the ocean cleanup bulls to really get to
a 90 percent reduction by by 2040,
which is incredible,
which I think is achievable both on the
influx side and the stock side.
Um,
but yeah,
so,
but I think that already before that,
I think maybe five years from now it
will just be sort of a steady operation.
And then for me it wouldn't be very
exciting anymore.
It's,
I would be involved until really the
end,
but maybe,
yeah,
maybe at some point in time I will be
able to,
um,
to sort of broaden my time over multiple
project.
But that's,
yeah,
that's at least years away,
um,
because yeah,
of course there's still a lot of things
that need to happen.
We need to first prove the technology
first and foremost this year.
Uh,
then we have to scale up,
um,
you know,
raise hundreds of millions to build this
entire fleet out.
Uh,
then therefore more patches in the
world.
We need to make it into a self
sustainable business and then we also
need to think about what can we do on
the source side.
So,
so there's quite a few pieces of the
puzzle is still there to be a to be
found and put together.
Um,
yeah.
So I won't be bored for the next few
years for sure.
You certainly won't be one of the
reasons why I'm asking this about you
and what your ideas are with cleaning up
other problems in the world as because
there's millions of people listening to
this and there might be another boy in
out there who's a young kid who says,
well,
why don't we do this or how come this
hasn't been done or why,
why hasn't someone tried this?
And next thing you know,
someone who's figuring out how to
extract heavy metals out of the bottom
of the ocean.
Sure,
sure.
I think the thing that will be will be
great and yeah,
I'd definitely welcome people to sort of
just to start and um,
yeah.
What kind of other thoughts?
Well,
I think another thing that's important
then when people try and solve problems
is that they actually think about how to
solve the problem.
I think there's a lot of people that are
very,
um,
yeah,
very well meaning and they want to get
involved.
But then what happens is that they sort
of think about it so at least I can kind
of make a dent and then hopefully that
dense sort of grows.
But I think what's,
what a lot of people forget to do is
that when they sort of start tackling a
problem,
they forget,
sort of look at the whole problem with
first and see what sort of,
what's required to actually solve the
whole problem.
And then I'm sort of reason your way
back to,
well,
what's the first step that I need to
take?
Because if you don't do that well then I
think it will be very hard to kind of
get the scale you need to actually sort
of solve,
solve the problem.
Um,
so,
and it's,
yeah,
I can imagine,
can be quite intimidating to think about
that.
But um,
yeah,
I think that would get us to much more
sort of effective solutions to sort of
this sort of top down problem solving as
I would call it instead of sort of
bottom up some problem solving.
So when have you talked to anybody that
also had an idea of how to clean up the
Pacific garbage patch?
Now I've read about other proposals from
the past for sure.
But no one is really actively pursued
anything.
Um,
so I didn't know.
But the thing is of course all those
other ideas were based on sort of boats
and nets that would go fishing plastic
taking 79,000
years for,
for just one.
Pat.
She,
there was one that I saw that looked
like some gigantic floating thing.
It looked like a spaceship and he was
kinda like moving across the surface,
sort of skimming it.
Is that one of those
see actually the,
some artist's impression of one of our
earlier concept.
I think that's probably what it was.
That was.
Yeah,
that was ours.
What other,
I mean,
if you don't mind talking about them and
what other ideas have you had in terms
of like cleaning things up?
Yeah,
I'm kind of hesitant to joke about them,
but I mean there's plenty of other
problems out there.
So if you just think about sort of what
are their big problems are out there.
How about water pollution?
Um,
yeah,
I usually what I do is like she,
I try and actively forced these ideas
out of my head just because sort of once
you have an idea it sort of starts to
grow and then sometimes you know,
with,
with any project you're doing there,
there are these weeks that things don't
go very well and sort of everything
seems to be against you.
And in those weeks though,
it's very tempting to start thinking
about well at this other idea and you
know,
and sort of starts to grow and you
should be careful that it doesn't take
over your entire month.
So I don't know what you're saying too.
Scattered and spread out.
Yeah.
So I think it's of paramount importance
for the,
this,
for the Azure team to happen is that I
stay 100 percent focused on what we do
if there's one mission rid the oceans of
plastic and that's what we're doing.
So what I usually do is I sort of write
them down in my notebook and keep it
next to my bed and that's where it stays
until maybe a few years from now.
So probably when you were to ask me
what's the top three ideas,
other ideas that you have,
I wouldn't be able to,
wouldn't even be able to say them
because yeah,
they're sort of out of my hand and then
I really tried to keep it there.
Um,
but,
um,
I mean,
what's,
what I can say is that they're all sort
of technology based.
So they're all things that are possible
now,
but I want to make possible in the
future and there are sort of all
connected in terms of negative side
effects of,
yeah,
of civilization.
And trying to sort of make sure that
that doesn't backfire to us.
What I always like to do is I try to
think like if we sort of try to imagine
a future in 10,000
years from now,
um,
how do we make sure that civilization is
there,
but,
you know,
zooming out,
humanity's still there as zooming
further out,
just general life can,
can prosper and yeah,
when I look at if I tried to extrapolate
the current situation to the next 10,000
years,
I don't think we're at that point yet,
but I think it's um,
yeah,
it's a challenge that we'll have to sue
so.
Well,
it's certainly a challenge that we're
going to have to solve and challenge
that I would hope more people like you
tackle and start approaching these
issues with the sort of 10,000
year mindset.
I'm a big one,
of course with the ocean is overfishing.
Yeah,
for sure.
Um,
yeah.
I mean,
one thing say retinue of credit,
of excitement and a lot of startups in
the area of,
of artificial meat,
right?
Yeah.
Why not artificial fish,
fish meat,
right?
Because there seems to be this natural
evolution from sort of wild hunting to
farming to sort of this more a lab grown
stuff that doesn't involve killing or a,
all these resources being wasted and on
land were kind of in Stage two now is
they're going to stage three protein
next few decades.
But if you look at phishing,
it's still just hunting,
right?
So it's still just wildcard.
Most,
most,
most fish,
there's some farm raised,
but it's also fun to be not as valuable
or as healthy.
Yeah.
And I think they also use a lot of wild
caught fish as a feedstock for these
farmed fish.
So that's kind of odd.
But yeah,
but that seems to be served as mentor
evolution.
So I think that would be a way to,
to kind of solve that.
Um,
and m.
But isn't there a potential.
I mean,
if we're looking at this in terms of
longterm of what we've done with plastic
and the downside,
there's potential downsides to even this
lab grown stuff.
Like we don't know really the health
consequences of consuming it yet.
We don't know what the side effects are.
We don't know what sort of byproducts
are created in manufacturing this stuff.
Yeah.
Um,
possibly and we need to
look carefully at this.
Uh,
but I think a decent paper does have a
lot of potential of being able to do
more with less.
Yeah.
I'm going to wait for awhile.
I just want,
I just,
I don't know,
it just seems to me like,
boy,
this could be one of those early adopter
things.
It could be A.
Yeah,
disaster.
Yeah.
Well,
yeah,
I show that dude.
Good testing there.
I'm sure they do too.
I mean,
I'm,
I'm sure I'm just ignorant,
but I'm still paranoid.
I would just go,
what are you doing?
What's going on?
How'd you make that?
You made it out in the lab.
Okay,
good luck eaten it.
I'll be over here.
I mean,
it's funny how thinks sort of,
um,
it's,
something's just take a lot of time to
sort of get used to another thing sort
of once it's,
it's there.
You kind of used to it in a second.
The example,
like earlier this week I was driving a,
um,
a,
a tesla on,
on autopilot.
And as driving it for five minutes and
then already you're kind of doing your
emails and then when you take it off,
it just feels like you're back in the
stone ages when you're just kind of have
to drive this yourself.
It's so weird.
So,
so you,
you do your
email while you're driving,
you're not even paying attention to the
machine and make sure that it doesn't
hit some homeless lady who steps out off
the median,
like say this did happen over a car.
Yeah,
I mean I think this things like this
will come up more rapidly than people
think and I think people will be very,
very quickly that we'll use to it.
But aren't you?
You're supposed to like look at the
road.
Right?
And that's supposed to be staring down
at your laptop.
Yeah.
Okay.
I just erase everything I said for the
past minute or two.
Have you ever seen the video of the guy
is falling asleep and San Francisco
traffic now he's completely asleep.
He's behind the wheel that tesla like
this and the car's slowing and going
with the pace of traffic.
It's really fascinating because this
happened so quickly.
I remember a buddy of mine got a tesla a
couple years ago and he's like,
dude,
I can let my hands off the wheel on the
highway.
I'm like,
really?
Like,
that's happening already,
but it's not just happening like people
plug into their navigate here.
This guy look at him.
This guy is stone dead asleep in his
tesla in bumper to bumper San Francisco
traffic and the car is performing
flawlessly and hurt their business.
This Dutch guy actually just went to the
back office,
like on the back seat and started
changing his clothes and.
Oh God.
Yeah,
and then apparently that they now
included the safety feature that you
kind of have to touch the wheel every
minute of it.
Oh,
that's a new thing.
Yeah.
BMW,
I believe,
has a similar system,
but you have to have your hand on the
wheel at all times.
Yeah.
It's pretty better until it's flawless.
It's.
Yeah.
I would imagine.
People probably do and all kinds of
freaky shit in their cars while this
thing is on autopilot,
it's really don't.
Yeah.
It's quite amazing how,
I mean there's.
You're just about to show a video of
Tesla autopilot crash compilations,
saving people from crashes is what it's.
Oh yeah.
Oh,
I'm sure it does.
What's unbelievable is how few crashes
there are and they said they'd been two
fatalities so far.
Okay.
How many fatalities per capita versus
non autopilot cars?
I mean,
I would imagine it's far less.
Yeah.
Obviously these cars are also just safer
in general,
so they're not much safer than a 19
nineties Toyota Corolla or something.
So in terms of the way the construction.
Yeah,
just safer when they crashed,
so I didn't know how they compared the
sisters statistics,
but yeah,
I,
I'm,
I'm very impressed too.
It was fun trying it out.
Yeah,
I'm impressed and I'm very hopeful.
The only,
my only concern I had my friend Matt
Farah was on last week and he's a car
expert and they've actually started an
organization to save human driving
there.
They're literally going to be like
lobbyists to,
to stop.
It doesn't get Ben.
Yeah.
Well,
that's the concern is that one day
they're going to say you cannot drive
your own car,
and they're really worried that.
What was the name of his organization?
Do you remember?
Okay.
So,
but the,
the,
you know,
they're very serious.
He's like,
it's going to happen quicker than you
think you're going.
It's going to be very difficult to drive
your own car and then it's going to be
illegal.
Yeah.
Maybe they should keep areas like the
highway one or anything like that.
Just something,
some freaky road or people can get
crazy.
Look,
man,
I'm steering.
I'm hitting my own brakes.
Yeah.
I mean,
again,
these are things that it's most likely
inevitable.
I mean,
this,
this technology,
the way it's progressing,
it's going to be safer.
It's going to be healthier,
lower emissions.
All these variables that are going to
come into play where people are gonna
say no,
there's just the benefit of driving your
own car is not worth the detriment to
society.
Yeah.
And next to that,
uh,
just if you think about the normal rate
of converting the entire car fleet to
electric,
it would be around 20 years because
that's sort of how long cars last and
you only produce a few hundred million
cars a year and there's billions of
cars.
So,
um,
so,
you know,
if you don't want that to take 20 years,
well I think autonomy than really has to
come into play because if you have
autonomous cars,
you need much less cars out there than
you would if you would have to drive
themselves because obviously cars are
just driving maybe three percent of
their time,
they're just being parked so they can
drive themselves.
I think the utilization of the number of
cars will be much higher.
And um,
I think that whole transition to
electric cars would happen much faster.
It's a human driving or association,
a Human Driving Association is what it
is here.
Pull it,
pull it back up again so you can.
Got It.
Yeah.
The war on driving is here.
A little paranoid.
They're a little paranoid,
but you gotta remember Matt Farah is a,
an automotive journalist,
so his livelihood depends on talking
about cars and he's a real legitimate
car.
What does this wrong answer?
What does that pick?
The electric car.
Oh,
you clicked.
It says wrong answer.
You go there.
It takes you to their shop.
Well,
why is this a shame?
Oh,
I get it.
That's just a joke.
Why would it be the wrong answer?
It's just an an answer.
Do you drive?
Do you drive an electric car?
A regular car?
Actually,
I don't have a car.
You don't know.
And why don't you ever read any cars?
You just have a.
have a bike,
but it's fucking freezing there.
Yeah,
the coat drive.
Wow.
Okay.
Hardcore.
Listen,
I'm a big fan of Holland because a
kickbox.
So you guys have some of the greatest
kickboxers of all times came from this
one small place.
It's very unusual.
No.
Why is that?
I have no idea.
Yeah.
We just have to punch people.
I guess when you did cut you off at the
Carthage.
Oh,
is that what it is?
But Holland is a very unique place,
isn't it?
I mean it's a,
it's a very unusual country.
I mean,
yeah,
sometimes people wonder why do you think
this is based on Hollander is there came
out of Holland and for us it makes a lot
of sense and that we live below sea
level.
So we're like,
we have pray per capita the highest
number of hydraulic engineers and
maritime engineers' blessing.
So it's just very good access to human
capital and um,
yeah,
so,
so pretty makes sense for us to be there
as an option for engineering companies
that support us and are involved with us
contractors.
Uh,
so.
So for us it's not pretty very strange,
but I don't know about the other things.
There's quite a lot of innovation coming
from such a small country.
Yeah,
a lot of innovation and really unique,
intelligent people.
I've met a lot of people from Holland
and they just really fascinating people.
Wim Hof.
Wim.
Yeah.
I've never met him,
but fucking guys the best.
And so lovely.
He's just such an amazing person.
Every time you're around them you're
like,
feel better.
Like somebody like some coffee.
Oh,
I know.
He's just,
he's very contagious and I mean I have,
I have quite a few friends from Holland.
You could check your watch.
You got to take off soon.
Right.
So fuck you.
Okay.
Um,
it's just,
uh,
I am fascinated how,
how variable people are and how these
cultures like Holland sort of arise and
I just find so many people from Holland
to be.
I'm waiting to meet assholes from
Holland.
I'm sure you must have them,
but they do it this,
they take from that with the people that
I've met from Holland or friendly and
happy.
It's a very unusual place.
Yeah,
no,
sure.
Yeah,
I,
I mean,
I kind of feel the same way about the US
west coast as well.
Um,
it's just,
um,
yeah,
I mean I'd definitely be able to live in
a place like San Francisco maybe just
because of the.
Yeah,
the high priest,
the high percentage of engineers and
entrepreneurs that kind of makes me feel
at home.
But,
uh,
no,
but I mean us in general,
I feel like,
um,
yeah,
the people are very friendly.
I can tell you some,
some spots that suck.
Okay.
There's a few spots.
It's like,
yeah,
you're in a good spot right here and San
Francisco is a fantastic spot in terms
of innovation,
how well has this been received in,
in America and particularly in
California.
I mean obviously you're here to do some
business and talk to some people.
Is this something that people are very
excited about and you feel like there's
a lot of momentum behind it?
Actually us,
the,
the number one group of supporters for
us because we know we fucked up a lot
with the ocean and it's right there.
Maybe that's your target,
but no,
just I think people are very um,
yeah,
very supportive.
But maybe it's also because the
geography of the patch,
it's right between two US states like
Canada but different.
Um,
so yeah,
so it's um,
yeah,
I think we've received a lot of support
from the US.
Um,
I think that our biggest support group
is from here and like everyone I talk to
here they really want to get into.
So yeah,
I think the,
um,
yeah,
we're kind of lucky that it's next to
the US.
Yes.
So you've raised all this money,
is this going to be a profitable
business?
Actually,
so we're a non for profit entity,
so a,
we're not even allowed to make profit,
but eventually the idea is that this
sort of,
this plastic business would be sort of a
separate thing and that would then
create the funding for the cleanup.
So everything would be reinvested in the
cleanup.
Oh,
that's fantastic.
So do you have a name for the plastic
business?
Uh,
no.
right now it's just under the ocean
cleanup still we'll,
we'll,
we're actually thinking about some kind
of brand name,
but it's the next year.
Yeah,
please let me know.
I mean we'll promote the hell out of
that.
I think that's a fantastic idea.
And I'll try to buy as many things out
of ocean plastic as they can sell deal,
I think.
Yeah,
I mean think the more things you can
buy,
maybe plastic sale.
Get this guy,
you know that phone.
Where are you buddy that makes these,
it's a guy carves all these himself and
then makes these molds and then hand
paints all of these.
Wow.
Yeah.
He's a little wizard.
I don't know.
He's just,
he's a wizard.
He's a big wizard.
If it's is actual size or me now I'm a
little taller than me,
but uh,
my head's not that big either,
but yeah,
these things are uh,
I mean to have a line made out of
completely out of ocean plastic would be
amazing.
Maybe he'll do a Boyan version.
That'd be creepy.
Creepy,
creepy looking at me over there.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's a weird phase two.
But um,
yeah,
I mean there's,
there's really the sky's the limit in
terms of applications of your plastic
and uh,
and again,
I fist think it'd be so attractive to
people.
I mean,
especially out here,
California,
at least posing as being environmentally
conscious.
There's a lot of environmentally
conscious posers out here for sure.
I mean,
they would like to just be able to say
that and they're like,
oh,
my dog's leash is made out of
environmentally conscious class that we
put in the ocean.
I was actually a part of the expedition.
I was there.
That was a good idea.
Yeah,
I mean really just,
I just think the sky's the limit in
terms of just the attractiveness of that
kind of plastic.
Yeah.
And on one hand at the problem that
everything is made out of plastic,
but it does give a huge potential for
alternative materials.
Like there's ocean plus.
Yeah.
What do you feel you're going to be
doing when this is done?
Like say if you get to this point where
most of the stuff's pulled out of the
ocean and what do you,
what,
what do you plan for the future?
You're 23 years old.
I mean,
you can basically do anything you want.
Sure.
Um,
maybe go on a holiday for a month and.
Yeah.
And then I'll probably just be working
on the next one.
I think this is what I love doing and
yeah,
I hope I'll get the opportunity to work
on many more problems like this in the
future.
So you feel like you will be a problem
solver,
like that's your thing
that be.
I should put that on my business card,
problem solver.
Why not?
Yeah,
I mean that's essentially what you are,
right?
I think there's just nothing more fun
than sort of solving a problem as.
And when you think about project like
the ocean cleanup,
you're sure you're solving the southern
part of a massive problem,
but just the whole road to it.
It's just like one little problem after
another little problem and yeah,
I just think it's just very sort of
intellectual intellectually satisfying
to be sort of confronted with this new
weird problem and then you can have to
sort of think how to solve them.
And as you know,
as the CEO,
you're sort of the accumulation zone,
the garbage patches it were for problems
within your own organization.
So everything that other people cannot
solve sort of end up with with you.
Um,
and yeah,
kind of,
I kinda like that.
It's a,
it's this fun thinking about things.
So for example,
just this week we had a,
like a,
I think it was last week,
so on Monday that was,
so we have this assembly yard and there
was a fence that was seven meters.
I'm too far to the left and there was
just this,
uh,
this email from the,
from the government saying,
well,
if you don't move it within 10 days you
have to stop your operation and I go,
Shit.
Um,
but yeah,
I mean,
so this little problem and you just have
to do a few calls and think about,
well,
how can we now arrange the assembly
yards in a way that it's still big
enough so we can assemble this 2000 feet
thing.
Um,
and then the next day turned out there
was sort of a slight misalignment of one
of the connections strips on one of the
flotation elements of the system.
And you Kinda have to figure out how can
we still attach it while I'm sort of
working with this and you know,
sort sort of just details,
but there are details on a daily basis
and yeah,
that kind of what makes it fun for me,
if it would all go fall asleep would be
pretty boring.
Well that's what's fascinating about a
guy like you,
is that your personality perfectly
aligns with this kind of problem.
I mean,
and that's a very unusual thing.
Did you,
were you a puzzle solver when you were a
kid?
Were you into like mysteries?
Like what is.
I'm not really,
they're just billing thing.
So actually,
so one of the things that I did it funny
anecdote is when it was,
think it was about 13 years old,
I had this idea of doing,
getting into the Guinness Book of
Records with launching a model rocket.
So it was already into those kind of
things and build them myself and they
shoot up like 300 feet in the sky.
Um,
and what that then do,
I was sort of organized this whole thing
with like there was media and we had
sponsors and we at the university
collaborating and we just had the sports
field with 300 people who were all at
the same time.
They would all launch the rocket and
actually I think we launched like 213 of
them at the same time and actually got
the Guinness Book of Records.
So I always had my projects,
let's put it that way.
Have you thought about potentially
working with companies that produce
environmental waste,
like maybe a company brings you on as a
problem solver for some sort of an issue
that they have a residual issue of
something that they produce?
Um,
yeah,
I mean I don't think it will be very
interesting to be a consultant or
anything,
but um,
yeah,
I mean definitely sort of after this I
want to do sort of solve more work on
more bake challenges.
Yeah,
like oil spills,
things along those lines.
Um,
yeah.
I mean you can keep guessing,
but yeah,
you'll see,
you'll see.
I'm sure.
I'm sure we will see.
Well listen man,
I'm so happy that you exist.
I'm so happy that there's someone out
there that's actually doing something
about this and uh,
I've,
I've seen,
like I said,
I've seen many of your talks.
I think it's a comprehensive approach.
I think it's amazing and I really hope
that something comes out of this.
It really works well.
Thanks so much.
Thank you.
My pleasure.
And thanks for doing this please and
tell people one more time how they can
get to your website.
Yeah.
So it's the ocean cleanup.com
are also social media,
just at the cleanup to follow us as we
launched the first system this summer.
And your social media accounts are a boy
and slept less lat.
Yes.
B O y a n s a t that's twitter,
instagram,
everything.
All the above.
Yes.
Thank you.
Boy,
this was what,
a lot of fun.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you.
Alright,
that was great man.